why why is there so much hate in the
world we should all just love each other
what makes you say that if a lot of
people love each other the world will be
a better place to live think about that
but nope
you all just gotta hate what makes you
say that I made a respectful video
talking about my favourite youtuber and
just look at all the dislikes I'm gonna
read some of the comments just so you
understand the pain and suffering I have
to endure as a youtuber and remember if
a lot of people of the world would be a
better place to live
haha you think you're funny hell no this
video is just for views to pay your rent
for this month this never thinks I pay
rent
that's cute well if you're so rich why
don't you pay with food shut the [ __ ] up
leave haha first nick is not fat and
second Jake Paul is always going to be
better than you you know it always
especially hurts when they have an
avatar of a furry wolf Angel get [ __ ]
Rex to bicker
the case I'm a maverick fish there's so
much there's something wrong with this
comment I don't know where to begin
leave Jake Paul alone man you act like
you're the best youtuber if I had to
pick my favorite youtubers I wouldn't it
wouldn't be you come on man
at least top five please top ten I'll
take a top ten from you Nathan
please Jake poll is the best pitch the
comma it's important you basically
called Jake Paul the best [ __ ] stop
passing it and by the way Jake Paul
roasted you so much I described to them
so much and you're next PewDiePie time
and missed [ __ ]
no not time ten anyone but time ten and
you're a dick ah God if you're a Jake
Polar's like this post how can do many
people like this guy he's not even funny
how can do many people how can do many
people like this guy I may not be funny
with this comment is hilarious [ __ ] you
pedi pear oh my god Peter pie you are
such a bully
you should be talking Jake Paul not the
rest of the team ten members you have no
frickin right to talk about Nick
Crompton saying that he's fat just like
I have no right to tell you you're ugly
but I'm saying it because you died died
serving man Taylor immunised goes hard
holy [ __ ] and I'm sorry I apologize to
make Compton he is the most beautiful
specimen I've seen in my life
I want to dip him in a frying oil you
know who is fat you're not funny
stop lying you're so bad you're dumped
Jake Paul is better than yo you should
quit YouTube stop saying bad words my
friend said if you say bad words you're
gust saying it too you're saying it to
yourself and you mean devil face devil
face devil face devil face never fake
devil face never face pale face
everybody ever good faces Jesus cry it's
kind of cute I gotta it's kind of cute
this comment please watch Logan's diss
track
because have her brother messed up but
he still got his Disney contract ah oh
[ __ ]
the Polar's go hard [ __ ] I really wish I
still had that Disney contract that was
kind of better I don't know why it was
this one so [ __ ] late oh it's so good
[ __ ] Nick Oh had to pull the Disney
contract card god dammit
at least he knows how to rat that's
right Kendrick Lamar at least JP knows
how to rap guys don't judge JP without
fully comprehending his intense and raw
talent if you think that being on Disney
is lame
hell no I never think I never thought
that oh wait I'm sorry your videos only
get 1 to 4 million viewers but this one
got 10 million for having Jake's name is
it [ __ ] unbelievable no you're right
I really have barely any videos over 10
million so it's really a struggle I
really need to put people's name in the
title Jake might actually be the best
you youtuber maybe better than you Puetz
he gained 5 million subs in six months
that's more than 500
that's more than 500 thousand subs per
month per month because you know I've
never gained 5 million subs in 6 months
that has never happened more than once
it just I've never been fortunate enough
because it's never done before you know
I never got 10 million subs in 6 months
as well that has never been done before
your content is [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
you handicap me damn people got really
mad huh Jesus
can I stand how pretty pie thinks he's
funny he's squinty I love Jake he's just
mad because Jake is getting more fused
than him he's talking about Nick but
Pete if I look starving if he wants to
talk about others did you make it so dis
track he's [ __ ] if anyone is he just
I hope he makes a video after this on
hate comments well I did actually I
don't like you be you talking about Jake
Paul and bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla stop talking about other
youtubers because you're not the boss
and you rule all over and you rule all
the other youtubers oh that's nice
that's cool
you don't rule ah [ __ ] literally this
was dumb Jake and the whole team made
the lyrics in a music video in one day
and it was all a joke I think Felix is
just jealous because Jake can actually
make a song I've made songs in a day
right I made many of them they're not
great either but at least I don't
[ __ ] flaunt like I'm tough [ __ ] for
it
could he be that one
when you don't wanna work female
underwear when you don't even care what
other people say I've done a lot of [ __ ]
just for attention just for a
[Music]
really where
I don't really want
overreact I don't wanna make a video
with I tried
[Applause]
oh dude PewDiePie parentheses you're
like 57 years old get a life
I run ironically you look 57 as well
what the [ __ ] I like how he skipped the
only two parts of the song my Tina's
twins and chase the part that wasn't
complete trash
well we bait basically most of it was
cut because I was so [ __ ] fed up I
was so sick when I shot that video I was
literally feeling terrible I didn't even
want to shoot it I was going way too
hard on it and in reality I don't care
like I think it's an objectively bad
video it's kind of like fun to make fun
it's like the room what makes you say
that it's fun to laugh at I don't like
have any grudge or hate or anything but
everyone just got so [ __ ] liked all
these kids just go crazy about it look I
know you're the king of YouTube but [ __ ]
you I'm Jack Waller for life [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you I [ __ ] hate you I wish you
would die that's a nice one
PewDiePie shut the [ __ ] up bro your
youtube name is gay PT pi the [ __ ] is
that bro can't you find someone
something else then PD PI at least Jake
Paul has a normal name and then you
tried to rap bro you had me dying just
don't try rap again and fix your eyes
that's a gun bro not a dick goddamn you
gotta check out your eyes aren't you
rich bro you [ __ ] can't afford to fix
your face and then you try to make fun
okay ah obese friend nah bro your trip
and that [ __ ] is messed up nobody gives
two bucks if he's fat or not bet he gets
more [ __ ] than yo like a look at
yourself and then talk bro you're you
look gay you sound gay and you think Ola
that cuz you gotta [ __ ] I can't okay oh
I'm glad that I didn't watch a YouTube
channel what what are you trying to say
oh I'm glad I didn't watch her YouTube
channel who do you what are you talking
about you're like I don't actually care
there seems to be so much drama going on
and like all these drama fuel channels
it's so easy to get swept into it I get
it
you make nine videos about it and then
they call you out for for milking it by
putting your name in the title for views
but then you do the exact same thing
yourself it's easy you know it's easy
views obviously you're gonna take it JP
I get it I used to be cancerous well
extremely cancer eysan I used to have
are you really young fanbase as well and
I think when when you had a young fan
base they really they really look at you
differently they don't criticize you if
you make mistakes and they're very
forgiving which is a really nice thing
but it it kind of gets you blindsided
for when you make false speaking from
experience this first time that I ever
received hate on YouTube I got
completely blind sight as well and my
response to that was literally will [ __ ]
you I I still make more money than you
and you're just bringing me abuse
because you're hating on me and I kind
of see the same response from jake and
el and the pole gang from all this and
you know if that's what they want to do
that that's all fine but it's very
arrogant and it's very childish and I
know that because I used to be arrogant
and I used to be childish so I get it I
really don't care for drama I don't care
for beef I don't care about anything if
I see stuff that's fun to react to I'm
gonna do it anyway that's it for me for
now see ya see ya
see you later my family which I love so
dearly you guys are like my family
now excuse me because I have other
business to take care of I'm a very busy
youtuber got hydraulics it was worth the
enormous prize
we wished on a star and a snowman came
to life kids table kids table the place
to be
his little kids table don't you agree
kids table kids table the place to be